what's up gq it's megan stallion aka the
high girl coach and i am going
undercover on the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
twitter oh jesus i'm not ready for this
y'all know i'm a freak it's my favorite
line of [ __ ]
why is megan court explaining to a judge
why she a freak
i'm just letting y'all know i would go
say it in front of the judge
like this is how true this is i'll put
my right hand on it
[Music]
how you say this quinoa core key aura
korra
why is society so bothered by the song
[ __ ]
by cardi b featuring megan's daddy girl
i don't
know why does me having a whop
offend you one year it was bad to have a
draw
ap so now y'all
mad because we got wet ones y'all man
gotta make up y'all mine
twitter what anime do you watch i am
wholeheartedly curious
i love my hero academia i love attack on
titan
i love bleach of course i love naruto
i'm watching black butler right now i'm
watching black clover too
i like soul eater that one was fire okay
man i just i watch a lot of anime okay
so stallion please explain why
everyone's seeing you from san antonio
i'm 100 from houston texas but
my mother was pregnant with me in
houston my grandmother is from san
antonio
and she was like you need to come had
this baby in san antonio
so my mama drove to san antonio had me
in the hospital
and took me right back to the age post
it
okay so i tweeted it's only like three
more months left in 2020 yes god
and he said so we are for sure 2021
gonna be that different asking for the
billions of people on this planet
if i could see the future i would tell
you that answer
but i can't so let's just pray that 2021
is going to be better than 2020 has been
this is insane like we thought we was
going to be flying cars by now
and really everybody just tearing up
next this thing ain't got no tattoos i
just peeped i never seen nothing on her
body
girl no i don't have any tattoos i've
always been scared to get a tattoo
because my mom was always like
don't you get a tattoo i'ma whoop your
ass and i'll be like yeah i'm hurry
so it's just always been in the back of
my head tattoos equal whooping
next hey queen your wing i want to be
winging what's the trick
girl you really gotta have like a steady
hand i guess and you really have to
find the right eyeliner pencil i use
liquid eyeliner and it has to be like
super pointy that is my key to success
of drawing the perfect wing summit
what is the breed of your new dog tan is
a cane corso
and he is just amazing four endos my two
little frenchies they really be bullying
him like they've been jumping him lately
and i'm like y'all better enjoy bullying
him while he's small because
in three more weeks he's gonna be way
bigger than all of us
post it wikipedia
megan originated the viral catchphrase
or something on social media
she first used the phrase in a tweet on
april 14 2018.
yeah i did i mean i really originated it
in my head
and then i put it on social media doing
real high girl [ __ ] means just doing
what you want to do
being the baddest b you can be and not
caring nobody got to say about it
and just being unapologetically you
submit
making the stallion sites beyonce pimp c
little kim biggie smalls and three six
mafia as her biggest influences
though this is true i also said my
mother
put that on there wiki cora
how did megan say and get her name i'm
from texas
and in texas guys call girls that are
thick fine and tall
stallions i saw this one thing on
youtube it was like megan the stallion
calls herself the stallion because she's
the black stallion and she's in the
illuminati and she about to come make
the world in and i was like
why me so yeah that was something dumb
that i saw
how good is making the stallion as a
singer
i used to think that i and i'm just
laying but like i'm not
that good of a singer in my opinion but
like if you throw me in the booth you
know
put a little sauce on it i think i smell
pretty good
i'll be singing my own hook sometimes
how did megan nostalgian get famous well
i like to think that i was famous ever
since i came out the womb
but probably when i started doing a lot
of ciphers
next this megan is saying right home
reps
yes yes she does growing up i watched my
mom
write her own reps i definitely write my
own music
i love writing music what is the meaning
behind the song savage
about making the stallion savage is just
like an extension of this real hot girl
[ __ ] that i'll be talking about
i am a savage and i am also classy and
bushy and ratchet
and sassy and moody and nasty as y'all
may know that by now as well
so you know i have to put it in a song
post it
does megan the stallion have a degree no
i do not
but i am working towards it and
hopefully fingers crossed i graduate
2021
next instagram no
seriously it's actually me where you get
your nails done that girl
my girl could come to my house and do my
nails and she's fire
next this person said damn how many dogs
you got
girl four i have dose four
five and ten
youtube y'all be saying crazy stuff on
youtube and i don't even really think
it'd be y'all
like i think it'd be like bots and i
don't know where bots come from
but y'all need to fix that
[Music]
it says her complexion is flawless it
looks like she's already wearing
foundation in the beginning
what y'all know what's up girl you know
i have foundation on already
see i came with my brows and my base
done this was the eye tutorial so i had
to
come naked on my eyes not my face but
next time i'll take it from the
beginning but thank you for that
compliment it's really hard to get your
complexion to look flawless
submit why is nobody talking about her
hair this woman can pull off any damn
hairstyle that's what i call it
thank you shout out to kellen
next but is it really a meg song if she
doesn't say
ah at least five times no it's not
because i probably
said it five times in the ad libs i come
on the song like that i end the song
like that
just so y'all know the look just
solidified that i'm about to just go off
on this
submit this has been you know
surprisingly pleasant
that's it i'm signing off the internet
[Music]